the world is invisible to the blind
fearful but at the same time the blind
people withdraw themselves from the
surrounding and they make them invisible
unless the people who are sighted
actively try to find them out they will
remain in the dark
my first visitation that one was with
one great missionary we travel to an
island there was a small medical clinic
and at the end of the day he said did
you see how people are suffering here
and he just ignited my feeling my first
introduction to blindness was my
grandfather's I used to sit beside him
on his bed and he used to put his hand
on my head on my shoulders and try to
feel how much I have grown up she
couldn't see me but he could fill me my
grandfather is still with me whenever a
treat a blind patient in the cataract
his face comes in my mind so maybe that
was subconsciously in my mind and that
pulled me in the field of eye care
three body muscle worst again inaudible
lot of only Hanukkah really bother jana
chuda Shalini is taking the struggle da
chimichenga loom bulletin on a chapter
honey for a singular fashion can you
Holloway's away she opening the Java
Korea star pair American boots even a
niche Hamas bhagavad watch October some
Cola locally I'm Yuri Marston is the
activation observe subjective Laramie
addictive an ancient enemy are spent on
doors and barrage at the water
mm tell me
Joseph I mean shut up was a Welshman
today that my Bangladesh ally hello Jojo
new year on all the stuff you love
watching by dr. mothers of the dinar at
all the Nami do not addictive I know
Murtaugh she told me came to this island
to work in an organized way to three
years back initially people who are not
trusting us take the case of Muhammad he
went to a quark and now Muhammad is
totally blind is irreversible had there
been a vision center Muhammad would have
gone to the vision center that process
would have said Muhammad's eyes were
yellow Vijay but Roberta conductivity
than immediate relative ochita because
you wonder I can open the kitchen fire I
will need to make the vegetable was here
as will be matching 19 surround the
quarry
there are many people affected by
bilateral cataract at a very young age
we call it a hereditary cataract just
think of nazma nazma z-- mother also had
the same situation she couldn't afford
treatment because of poverty and she
gave birth to five children out of five
children four had a similar condition at
the end
why did you can they okay that wicked
I'm Sharon Ivanka passport okay to our
warm honey cotija sock down below again
for everybody to Armando - Tony if it's
what you are aware of are hotter hotter
than a boy sits here we know this is
Alton we are hardware news I gave him a
hotel or hardware me
so last
when they become adolescent the added
fear is the sexual harassment the girls
always confined themselves inside the
house they don't go out
I was actually invited to watch with
your life before terminology was
delivered today I'm their bond with a
prisoner
there is a saying that when Muhammad
doesn't come to the mountain the
mountain goes to Hamid same is true for
I care in remote community they collect
the patients from the different islands
by boat and by bus they take them to the
base hospital the surgery is done and
they are sent back to their villages the
follow-up is done at primary eye care
centers so that's the network now
operating we are recruiting more and
more people from the island to train
them up expand the services that way we
foresee that the network will spread and
people will access the service and that
will create positive I help seeking
behavior among the people of the island
I was very moved by watching the life of
nazma so when they were going home
nas was father say doctor in last two
days nazma has become too naughty he was
very happy to say so and I was happy to
hear as well